receding gums are not attractive
symptoms include tooth sensitivity
and oral health issues but a lot of
people avoid
gum grafting surgery because they've
heard it's painful
and i did this about 20 years ago and it
was after years of research though dr
john chao developed pinhole gum
rejuvenation
the first minimally invasive treatment
to correct
gum recession he joins us now to tell us
how this
works thanks dr chao for joining us
thank you for having me so why should
people care about receding gums in the
first place
well that's a really great question
receiving gums
for for one thing are unaffected
and they can also cause true sensitivity
and lead to other oral tissues as you
mentioned
but the aging process and health
problems are also factors
receiving gums can affect anybody at any
age even younger folks
so you have this new treatment it's
pinhole gum rejuvenation
how does it work well
pure gum rejuvenation being the first
minimally invasive treatment for
receiving gums
that requires no scalpels no sitting and
minimum downtime
the entire procedure is done through
tiny pinholes made in the gums
first the gum is numbed with a local
anesthetic
then using special instruments that i
designed they trained dentists
freeze the gum tissue and guides the
gums to cover the exposed roots
the pinholes heal quickly and most
patients report
little or no pain and virtually no
downtime
this encourages you to treat me yeah for
anyone who has had a gum graft this is
revolutionary and they understand how
big a deal this is
what inspired you to come up with this
or how did you come up with this
well mostly like most inventions peter
was developed
to develop fulfilling need that i saw in
my own patients
like you who had experienced
difficulties
with recovery painful painful uh
symptoms and long recovery time so
this was part inspired me to begin
research
and development of the piano technique
to date i personally trained over 3500
dentists
from across the country and around the
world due to the demand
for dentists i'm continuing training
courses for new online classes for
dentists people can find a trained
dentist now
in most cities and towns across the usa
of course
including beautiful las vegas you showed
us a little bit about
how it works what is the recovery time
in this case
recovery time is practically zero
uh patients love the results and they
see the results
instantly the same appointment and
because there's no cutting there's no
suturing
uh there's hardly any uh there's hardly
any
symptoms uh the next day or or so
there's hardly any downtime
the most they need maybe is one or two
timeouts and that's it it's fantastic i
know a lot of viewers going to want to
know
how they can find this where can people
learn more about it or find out if their
dentist does it
okay then go to pinhole gum
rejuvenation.com
and they can find dentists who are
trained in the pinhole technique and
train that and
dentist with needing treatment needing
to learn about the technique
can i can also find information on the
website
dr chow great stuff thanks for joining
us today really appreciate it
okay thank you for having me all right
rocky over to you